do you remember the audition for Vampire
Diaries oh dude it was hell this was of
the worst experience of my life I mean I
read for Ian Somerhalder's role first
and I got a call back uh then they then
I didn't hear from them I told you I
tested for some other shows and then
they I get a frantic phone call they've
done three rounds of testing they can't
find anybody for this roll of Stefan the
younger brother uh they'll bring you in
uh read for it I went in Redford they
said great you're testing the next day I
went back I went and I showed up and
because it started shooting in a week
they were testing I think 14 guys I'm
not exaggerating they were all there all
there you know you'd go in you'd read
for it once then they'd be like okay
wait outside then they'd come out with
like a clipboard and they'd be like you
go home and then some guy would be go
home with his bags and then they'd go
and okay read again and they would come
out okay you two go home boom those guys
and it like it was like this like I felt
like I was on Survivor